[Musique]
bien d'autres professeurs montfort
compressions ne perdons pas notre temps
aux vans billevesées entrons dans le vif
du sujet comment s'effectuent les
sondages et qu'est ce que c'est
exactement de la fourchette
whissell le traité d'une manière
scientifique et sur lequel je m'en
excuse et moi j'ai pris quelques notes
mérité en scientifique sont assez
difficiles
et bien voilà les sondages spéléologique
de l'opinion publique législatives
s'effectue l'espace à l'aide d'une sonde
électromagnétiques hydrofuge en mobile
sûrs de plastronner sommes salis
covalents et d'une fourchette électorale
en club street de finir below ignifuges
4 6 6 4
voilà qui est très clair c'est l'espoir
amont limpide c'est ça saute aux yeux
comme un comme une carte dans un taxi
d'intérieur très clair les ça fonctionne
comment à mener à bien ce là les termes
sont encore plus scientifique plus
difficile super mecs prennent des notes
mais douze ans prévoyait jean moulin
alors pour que ces deux éléments
organiques n'est ce pas puisse tenir
correctement leur rôle de catalyseur
universel il est aussi indispensable que
les cci protm en prêt naturellement ce
qu'il soit équipé l'un d'un bidule
hélicoïdal hans backe smocks hémorroïdes
au statique et l'autre d'une spa de
l'ultra chiadé en york y flor de
barsanuphe extra face à roddick c'est
limpide
n'est ce pas
sachant que vous étes être parce que
comme un rouge est dans le coma rouge et
non dans un chemin creux c'est ça ah oui
à tout cela naturellement tout cela
naturellement se bat fonctionnant
exclusivement la plaque simone aussi
adulé plextronics vols supprimés tic ça
explique tout pouvait pas ce que c'était
parce politique qu'est ce que ça veut
dire je vous l'demande de quoi on aura
les barrages
j'espère que la mitis lequel de la
plaque small spirit et tétouan méthode
qui a combiné de semer mieux fragnes
empirique l'oise et à l'état pur vous
suit et de trop nous y sommes filtrant
celui-ci ferait à l'état soeur je vous
suis parfaitement bénévoles à qui
doit-on l'invention des générateurs au
10e bout suite cheminée pour faire
l'amour oui
écoutez nous sommes ça faisait rire ses
rayons sous charlemagne
alors à qui doit-on l'invention de la
sonde et de la fourche et à un défi néo
ça remonte à la plus haute antiquité
oh oui aux rideaux y la preuve
l'invention de la sonde a sondé
l'opinion publique est de duels illustre
philosophe yves run drake mordicus date
encore lui et oui la saison connaissent
et qui je le rappelle pour mémoire bien
sûr ronde s'est vécu de 186 à 83 au fond
de la deuxième cour à droite avant jésus
christ et celle de la fourchette
électorale au célèbre théosophes
abstinent spartiates [ __ ] hausses des
six clubs qui vécut lui de 168 à 80
après la cueillette des olives en
thessalonique vient d'arriver un grand
monsieur
oui nous avons abordé les problèmes
techniques mais la black small
proprement dit qui l'a prise
donnons leur club ou de dire par qui par
qu'il a été il a été découvert
c'est ça sans doute vous voulez me
demander oui découvrir inventé oui c'est
cela c'est cela ou découvert à poissons
ou des biens s'est faite au soir au dos
bien sûr comme dans certaines lewy le la
plaque simone le spv tic ethic a été
entièrement découvert et ses immenses
propriétés kalki nomal foireuse
formellement reconnu par le génial et
mondiale chimistes physiciens
mathématiciens distillateur et
bouilleurs de cru ragarde syracuse qui
est l'homme qui va qui vécut de 2 105 à
103 avant pendant et après la récolte du
colza dans le péloponnèse et celle du
haricot en cas de série et bien se tenir
c'était même la fin des haricots à ce
moment je crois que ça serait ça a été
le coin des lentilles qui peut placer un
mot douze ans après je crois que nous
avons fait un pas important dans le
domaine de la vulgarisation scientifique
will grâce à vous et oui alors en
définitive est ce qu'on peut encore la
plaque small oui oui mais bien en bref
et en conclusion si j'ose dire n'est ce
pas osé le laos du bien ces murs jaunes
la plaque ce monstre du mythique
naturellement ce rappel est le seul et
unique argument valable inutilisable qui
permet d'assurer tout risque
la bonne marche de la machine à sonder
l'opinion publique et de l'excellent
flicage de la fourchette électorale
et oui sans la place monde ça ne peut
pas marcher c'est de la plaque small
simple à la fois dont on peut
l'améliorer mais oui mais oui mais oui
mais oui et je terminerai d'ailleurs
je pense là dessus c'est oui oui
toutefois toutefois de vaud et les deux
sur trois du mérite qui ça vous concerne
bien sûr car bon ça vous considère qu'un
concerné n'est pas forcément un imbécile
en état de siège
ledit gré sont pas non libyens ces gens
recommencent pas wei toutefois
l'histoire débuté bien sûr et
réciproquement com2us bien sûr toutefois
de vori de surcroît du mérite
on peut en augmenter le rendement du
placement et en accroître la puissance
en y ajoutant à titre le super pour en
faire du super et en partie égale un
mélange de most blazy de californie
voyez-vous qui à bord ni de quel si
fragile mais talbot rnic de molécules in
qui perd son froc riddick et de
particuliers hypo méfaits saïdal sait
bien que tout et je crois que nous avons
encore après des tas de choses à votre
compagnie en dieu vous savez c'est mon
lot c'est ma mission scientifique sur
terre n'est ce pas mon fils
écoute merci mon père
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]